alors attendez ou est ce qu'on essaie
déjà parce que oui on nettoie les fonds
déposés n'ont pas pris le temps du tout
de me dire où on était et ses premiers
jeux explique quand même fut le premier
fils de police non voyants et engagés
dans la force publique sur la rue non
mais le problème c'est que les collectes
sont partis sans me dire on était alors
on est rompu c'est non et si elle est
aux anges elysées wii points vers
l'europe moi je pense quand le rond
point
alors on est au point de changer d'ici
là attendez on a le bouquin va se
partager voulait alerter ap ouais alors
regardez qu'est ce que vous nous lisez
la gallia les banques là oui on veut pas
ça ne veut pas les bras on veut pas les
banques parce que je suis voilà live
arcade paris voilà alors rue de paris
alors on va chercher le
rue de la paix s'étaient lotissement
vous connaissez vous parce que moi je
suis pas dit si cette fois ci c'est au
lait alors c'est vraiment parce que
voilà
ah ben voilà une collègue justement
peut-être là c'est moi dites moi il ya
demandé le chef de l'ong ville désolée
je trouve que l'appellation proxes veut
travailler bien resterait pas enfin le
voile un collègue non voulait pas
demandé au collège c'est pas mon secteur
il ses bâtons secteur chez qu'elle
voyait ce coffret si la circulation
milieu lucas d'accord circulation mais
écouter benoît non soit ils se
retrouvent direct ah non non non non je
demande absolument être traitée 100 % en
mai c'est pas trop dur à non on
regardait ça se passe bien
c'est tranquille on a on alarme parce
que larmes c'est une vraie là moi aussi
j'ai dit comme vous ne trouvez pas ça
étrange de l'annoncer pas trouvé ça et
parce que j'aime bien votre mieux
comment cette branche dans la police ah
ouais non mais julien on peut être dans
la peau on peut être dans la police est
branché pour être dites moi comme je
suis le premier officier de police en
voyant dans la brigade wifi et donc
c'est mon premier jour de formation
non mais je plaisante pas est ce que en
présentant le connaissent non
alors vous cherchez quoi le palais de la
découverte
alors écoutez venez voilà venez on va
partager on va partager le plan la
regarder voilà
mais non mais on est tout près un oui
oui bah vous donc vous allez la volaille
connaît bien justement paul un collègue
à l'aider les rameurs oui madame mon
secteur pour la suite c'est pas sur
cette session pressée de le regarder
indiqué le chef qui demandait ce que
vous facile à la chaîne complexe
désolation milieu du quartier désolé
fond d'affairé circulation avant
d'alerter la police
or là on est où là voilà en quoi
défendre et non mais là là par exemple
on n'est pas du tout mais c'est ce que
je vous demandais ce que je veux sans
père
je termine ses collègues juste bien
collègues
voilà il va peut-être venir nous aider
renseignements les abîmer gt gt gt sur
champigny déploya le chef qui vient le
lien qu'il faudrait vous fassiez la
circulation au niveau du carrefour en
d'accord on va coûter bassim écouter ces
désordres du chef du chef
si tu veux commencer tu comprend une
chose de chefs ne dit jamais deux c'est
mieux mais c'est mon service c'est mon
service j'ai choisi on n'a pas pensé
j'ai choisi
[Musique]